quelqu'un qui m'appelle du royaume uni
qui est l appareil
oui c'est qui nabila aux bébés
commencent à ma chérie ma nabila d'amour
s'avachir id amour et ma chérie je suis
très content de t'avoir toi t'es où toi
là tu as to buy ma chérie tout se passe
bien
[Musique]
alors ici vous êtes confiné à dubaï ou
pas ma chérie tu est angoissé par tout
ce qui se passe ou pas ma chérie nantes
au matin thomas que j'aime fort en plus
une alors qu'est ce qu'elle doit faire
sans naby là parce que ça c'est une
question ce reste avec nos habits la
voilà si vous êtes avec confiné mine de
rien avec votre mari comme d'habiles à
elle a un enfant en plus
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle voit qui
commence à tousser elle voit qu'ils
commencent à avoir de la fièvre
elle fait quoi est-ce qu'elle continue à
s'en occuper elle le confie neil c'est
quoi la plante elle fait quoi alors en
france à l'heure actuelle si vous avez
de la fièvre et que vous avez vous tous
et sans signes respiratoires de
difficultés respiratoires
vous restez chez vous pour le moment
vous appelez votre médecin et si besoin
il donnera quelque chose peut-être un
anti bio des ateliers pourquoi ce qui
reste encore elles sont mal ou bail
elles n'ont elles restent de toute façon
s'il a attrapé le commis de 19
il ya de fortes chances pour qu'elle les
ait l'enfant on a bien vu qui avait pas
de risque si par contre dès qu'il ya un
signe de détresse qu'être voilà mais lui
un masque mais lui un masque déjà pour
éviter qu'ils contaminent nous ici on
considère que tout syndrome grippal et
est maintenant un kobe de 19 mai lui un
masque et éventuellement quand tu
t'approches de lui mais lui un masque
pour là mais c'est surtout lui qui doit
mettre un masque à l'heure actuelle
la preuve les nids dans l'est tu l'as
mis dans la chambre bleue marine aux
tomates une évidence quand tu as bien
fait ma chérie comment est à une autre
question à nous poser ma chérie je veux
la corse est la meilleure mais ce serait
trop davidas et non mais limite ses
intelligences qui s'est dit assez
intelligent c'est un paysan ce que tu
viens de dire est ce que tu t'es en
train de créer une double barrière en
fait voilà après on va laisser ce n'est
qu' un pro de ça il suffit de mettre un
masque ffp2 qui est prévu pour l an neuf
fois plus abc alors la farine mais deux
masques comme ça mais pour son mari il
doit pouvoir en avoir pas si leur ouais
c'est pas mal tu vois personne ne dit
non c'est pas si mal quand même il faut
essayer d'avoir sur son mari le coeur et
nabila tu sais que je t'adore monsieur
[Musique]
et moi et moi j'ai regardé ton programme
sur invasion du village le dit tu es
exceptionnel ça fait des années que je
crois en toi tu le sais et franchement
était la meilleure et tu me déçois
jamais ma chérie jouer de faire un gros
bisou et embrasse fort thomas aussi avec
réserve et ambroise thomas et je veux
voir les et je veux voir l'enfant
d'enfant de cet amour le fruit de cet
amour qui doit être magnétique
je t'envoie chéri écoute et lola ne
change rien on t'aime fort s'allume à
nabila c'est un amour est elle vraiment
saint amand s'est arrêté et mis dedans à
chaque fois dhabi là c'est pas con ce
qu'elle dit à chaque fois on croit que
l'homme avait tout le monde le prend
pour une idiote en fait c'est une fille
extrêmement intelligente aéré bassesse
brille elle gère très bien son truc